Mr girls I I want to ask you the
question that you aren't going to get
asked by Mr Palumbo because you're
debating him rather than MS mcclovsky
people report and you disagree that they
have a different anthropology than you
they don't agree with your you know
description of the soul and what they
say is I see my child you know I see
them light up when they get to dress in
the way they want I see them you know
feel more comfortable
even aside from those longer term
questions how can I as a parent be so
sure when you tell me that when I see my
child feel more comfortable they're
wrong and I'm wrong when in anything
else if they signed up for little league
and it really fit for them I would go
with it I would explore it and your
answer here is not so how do you answer
that sense of apparent sense of their
own child and that particular child's
response to a transgender you know
feeling I think this point by The
Phantom of Professor McCloskey is a very
good one because
it would seem to me that what what
transgenderism is proposing is is an
anthropology it's an idea about what
human nature is and so if it is true
then
it is true for children and I'm not
using this to suggest we get rid of
transiting the kids ultimately I think
that of course but but if it's true then
it would seem to me very cruel to
prevent a child from transitioning
especially before puberty because if you
can suppress a child's puberty and then
you can put them on cross-sex hormones
and then you can have the little boy
look more like a little girl he is going
to much more successfully pass as the
opposite sex than if he were to be put
on these kinds of hormones and have
these procedures much later it'd be much
more expensive it would be much more
painful and so if transgenderism is true
then I think
we have to trans the kids now it so
happens that transgenderism is not true
and there are people who are in all
various states and
even who have fallen into this kind of
transgenderism later on and so just as I
think it would be wrong to lead children
who were behaving in an irrational way
down this path I think would be quite
wrong to do that to adults as well Mr
Palumbo has conceded the point that at
the extremes of anorexia it would be
fine to force feed somebody or Force
somebody into hospitalization Mr Palumbo
has made the point that someone
suffering body identity disorder would
not be able to even to get this sort of
a surgery to remove a limb What doctrine
is right mind would do it I will point
out there were doctors today removing
the healthy breasts of 14 year old girls
so I think you can find a lot of quacks
out there in fact there have been quacks
who have performed this surgery but none
of us I think believes that we ought to
chop off the healthy limbs of these very
people so I just don't see why we
wouldn't apply that down the line
Professor McCloskey's position is a
consistent position and it's
consistently wrong and I think that if
we're going to be right here we have to
be consistently right to Brad's point
that he keeps saying why would you want
the government to do this why would you
trust the government I've said it before
I suppose I'll say it again in the
United States we are the government even
with all the corruption we are the
government and if if we surrender our
capacity for reason and moral conscience
if we really say that we can't know the
difference between true and false and
right and wrong then we're surrendering
self-government this is what John Adams
meant when he said the Constitution is
built for a moral and religious people
that wasn't soft soap and a nice
platitude he's saying that's how
self-government works if we surrender
that we lose the American project Mr
Palumbo I do want to ask you the same
parent who says
child
and the way they act when you know I
address them in one way or the other
when I put them with one group of kids
or the other it tells me they're happier
this way and uncomfortable the other but
you say I can't do this until they're
18. why well to clarify I'm okay with
them socially transitioning but I think
you know that that's not always where
people want to stop I agree so what
would you say to that parent the reason
that that is not appropriate is that
that child is two one too young to
really consent to the life-altering
possibilities of that but two going
through puberty
of your natal sex
are you okay some people were
transitioning to the front rows
a little worried about that
okay
so again I'd like to I'd like to ask the
question again because I think I think
the reason the noises are so loud out
there and the reason everyone got quiet
when we saw someone moving is that
people think the stakes of this question
are high they are and that parents worry
if they listen to you Mr Palumbo and
wait and act later they may not be
taking care of their child or loving
their child as they are and it sounds
like you're all right with them doing
that later but not earlier and I think
that's a that's a big burden of proof
for that so I I understand completely
and that's why I think this is a really
complicated issue I don't envy a parent
who has a child with severe gender
dysphoria I can see why they would be
incredibly torn on what the right thing
to do is
um but what I will say is that it's
actually the process of going through
puberty as your natal sex that often
causes gender incongruity to desist so
the problem is that now they go on
puberty blockers then they do
cross-sexual hormones they never
actually go that's why previously
decades ago when you had gender
incongruent youth many of them grew up
to be gay men or lesbian women and that
was because when they went through their
puberty they reconciled their gender
they realized the things they were
feeling didn't mean they were actually
is there a point after a certain trial
of puberty where you'd feel comfortable
with a minor transitioning when they say
I've given it a good shot Mr Palazzo
like like you said this works for some
people it doesn't work for me it's
that's why it's so hard to have the
government come in and set a
one-size-fits-all rule I have also said
that you know I think the age of consent
should be 18 but in some states it's 16
or 17. it would make sense to me then
that in those States you could also
transition gender at 16 or 17.
um but I don't know exactly where to
draw the line and that's part of my
point here is that Michael keeps saying
transgenderism is false and if it is
false it should be banned I don't
believe the government should be in the
business of banning false ideas
Michael's also said that transgenderism
is a false religion so then we want to
ban religions I'm wondering what
happened to freedom of religion what
happened to freedom of speech and also
the average federal bureaucrat has the
politics of Elizabeth Warren and I know
you can cite Noble things about
self-government but the truth is we have
a bloated bureaucracy that does not
represent the American people it is an
entrenched political class with politics
much different than yours so the idea
that we're going to make that government
the Arbiter of what ideas are true and
false and ban or eradicate some ideas as
a result of that seems to me not just a
bad idea on principle but incredibly
short-sighted for people from your
background in world view and values Mr
Knowles how do you think you would fare
under a government that has the reach
and you know
intimacy that you are advocating for I
think I would fare Fair fairly well
because well I agree with Brad's point
that we have far too many bureaucrats on
the federal payroll the recent upending
of laws concerning sex and gender have
come from elected and appointed
officials come from the Supreme Court
appointed by presidents it's come from
legislators in Charlotte North Carolina
and and all over the country so it has
been from representatives of people and
appointed officials who uh who have been
appointed by representatives of the
people and the people change their minds
that's one of the features of democracy
and so unfortunately the Supreme Court
1973 decided that there were some
imaginary right to abortion and this
error persisted for a long time and then
49 years later the court reversed that
decision in 2020
the Supreme Court made an error and
decided to interpret civil rights law
protections for sex as being protections
for sexual orientation and gender
identity which ironically undermines
civil rights protections for sex by
allowing the men to play on the sports
teams and go to the bathrooms and so in
this case I know Brad you keep
suggesting that I want this very narrow
authoritarian totalitarian view I don't
there are all sorts of questions where
I'm happy to leave things pretty open
but on certain issues where
only one side can can establish its
principle in society we have to come to
conclusions and I would come to the
conclusion that has prevailed for all of
human history not the one that cropped
up five seconds ago